a federal jury found Donald Trump liable
for the sexual abuse and defamation of
writer E Gene Carroll and ordered him to
pay 5 million dollars in Damages
Trump called The Verdict a disgrace in a
message on his social media Network true
social
Corrine Ramey covers New York
investigations into Donald Trump and has
been following the Civil Trial for the
journal she explains what you need to
know about the case and what the
consequences are for Trump
this lawsuit was filed in 2022 by Eugene
Carroll a writer and advice columnist
she alleged in the lawsuit that Donald
Trump raped her in the dressing room of
Bergdorf Goodman the Manhattan
department store in the mid-1990s he put
his shoulder against me to hold me
against the wall and at that point I
realized that I was in a very difficult
situation her lawyers tried to show that
Trump had what they call an Mo that he
sexually assaulted women in similar ways
and they did this through both the
accounts and to women but also by
playing the 2005 Access Hollywood tape
and I'm automatically attracted to
beautiful I just started kissing them
it's like a magnet
I don't either wait and when you're a
star they let you do it you can do
anything whatever you want grab them by
the
you can do anything from side chose not
to present any Witnesses at trial but
they said one reason for this is because
his defense was essentially that it
never happened that her story was a lie
it was inconsistent Trump has said he
doesn't know Carol and that he's never
met her now when you say in here
I don't know this woman and have no idea
who she was who she is
even though you're using the present
tense
you're referring back to your knowledge
as of when she first made the allegation
I still don't know this woman I think
she's a whack jab I have no idea I don't
know anything about this woman other
than what I read in stories and what I
hear I I know I know nothing about her
in the lawsuit she also alleges that
Trump defamed her in a 2022 social media
Post in which he called her account a
hoax and a lie and said she wasn't my
type Carol asked for damages for both
defamation and Battery one of her
lawyers said in a closing argument that
for each and Carol the case was not
about the money for Trump the immediate
impact is he'll have to pay the damages
that were ordered by the jury this was a
rape claim it was a rape case all along
and the jury rejected that but made all
the findings so
um we'll obviously be appealing those
other findings he's also sure to face
questions about the verdict as he
continues running for for the 2024
Republican Presidential nomination it
just compounds the various legal issues
that surround him right now
foreign
[Music]